pressions qui se sont amplifiées à la naissance de mes deux beaux enfants.
Bien que les femmes occidentales aiment nous donner des conseils
à nous, femmes arabes, pauvres et oppressées,
elles vivent des vies différentes avec des contraintes différentes.
Les femmes arabes de ma génération ont dû devenir leur propre modèle.
Nous avons dû en gérer plus que les hommes arabes
et faire face à plus de rigidité culturelle que les femmes occidentales.
De ce fait, j'aimerais penser que nous, femmes pauvres et oppressées,
avons des leçons utiles, durement gagnées à partager,
des leçons pouvant être utiles
à toute personne voulant prospérer dans le monde moderne.
Voici trois de mes leçons.
[« Fais de leur m*rde ton carburant. »]
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Il y a ce mot que tout le monde vend comme la clé du succès :
la résilience.
Qu'est-ce que la résilience et comment la développer ?
Je crois que la résilience est juste la capacité à transformer
les emmerdes en carburant.
Dans mon précédent travail, bien avant mon travail actuel,
je travaillais avec un homme que j'appellerai John.
Je faisais équipe avec John et travaillais dur,
en espérant qu'il me trouve géniale
et qu'il me soutiendrait pour devenir partenaire dans cette entreprise.
En plus de ma réussite sur mes projets,
j'écrivais passionnément au sujet de l'émancipation économique des femmes.
Un jour, j'ai pu présenter ma recherche à un groupe d'étudiants en MBA.
John faisait partie du public,
écoutant pour la première fois les détails de mon étude.
En avançant dans ma présentation,
je voyais John du coin de l’œil.
Il était devenu cramoisi
et avait glissé sous sa chaise sous l'effet d'une honte apparente.
J'ai fini ma présentation et ai été applaudie
puis nous sommes sortis et avons pris la voiture.
Là, il a explosé.
« Ce que tu as fait était inacceptable !
Tu es une consultante, pas une activiste ! »
J'ai dit : « John, je ne comprends pas.
J'ai présenté des indicateurs sur l'égalité des sexes
et des conclusions sur le monde arabe.
Oui, il s'avère que nous sommes aujourd'hui en bas du classement,
mais qu'ai-je présenté ou dit qui n'était pas factuel ? »
Ce à quoi il a répondu : « La base de ton étude est mauvaise.
Ce que tu fais est dangereux et brisera le tissu de notre société. »
Il a marqué une pause puis ajouté :
« Quand les femmes ont des enfants, leur place est à la maison. »
Le temps s'est arrêté,
je n'avais qu'une pensée qui tournait dans le chaos de mon esprit :
« Tu peux oublier ce partenariat, Leila.
Cela n'arrivera jamais. »
Il m'a fallu quelques jours pour absorber pleinement
cet incident et ces implications,
mais quand cela a été le cas, j'étais arrivée à trois conclusions.
Un : c'étaient ses problèmes,
ses complexes.
Ils peuvent être nombreux dans notre société
mais je ne laisserai pas leurs problèmes devenir les miens.
Deux : j'avais besoin d'un autre sponsor, et vite.
(Rires)
J'en ai trouvé un et il était vraiment génial.
Trois : je devais montrer à John
ce que peuvent faire les femmes ayant des enfants.
J'applique cette leçon tout aussi bien à ma vie personnelle.
En avançant dans ma carrière,
j'ai reçu beaucoup d'encouragements,
mais j'ai aussi souvent rencontré des femmes, des hommes et des couples
qui ont clairement un problème avec mon mari et moi
et notre choix de couple menant une double carrière.
Il y a ce couple bien intentionné
qui vous dit, ouvertement, lors d'une réunion de famille
ou entre amis,
que vous savez que vous n'êtes pas une super maman
vu le temps que vous investissez dans votre carrière.
Je mentirais en disant que cela ne m'a pas blessée.
Mes enfants sont la chose la plus précieuse pour moi
et penser que je les laissais tomber m'était intolérable.
Mais, comme avec John,
je me suis rapidement souvenue que c'étaient leurs problèmes,
leurs complexes.
Alors, au lieu de répondre,
je leur ai fait un de mes plus beaux sourires
et j'ai vu, très rapidement,
cette enseigne dans mon esprit.
[Soyez heureux, cela rend les gens fous.]
(Applaudissements)
En tant que jeune femme, dans ces situations vous avez deux choix :
vous pouvez décider d'intérioriser ces messages négatifs
qui vous sont adressés,
les laisser faire de votre vie un échec,
comme s'il était trop difficile d'accomplir quelque chose ;
ou vous pouvez voir la négativité des autres comme leur problème
et la transformer en carburant.
J'ai appris à toujours choisir la seconde option
et j'ai découvert que cela m'a renforcée.
Le dicton est vrai :
le succès est la meilleure revanche.
Certaines femmes du Moyen-Orient
ont la chance d'être mariée à quelqu'un qui soutient leur carrière.
Correction, je devrais dire « ont l'intelligence »
car vous choisissez qui vous épousez
et vous devriez épouser quelqu'un qui soutient votre désir de carrière.
Encore aujourd'hui, l'homme arabe
ne contribue pas à la moitié des tâches ménagères.
Notre société n'attend pas cela de lui
et cela est même mal vu.
Concernant les femmes arabes, notre société considère encore
que leur première source de bonheur devrait être le bonheur et la prospérité
de leurs enfants et mari.
Elles existent surtout pour leur famille.
Les choses changent mais cela prendra du temps.
Cela signifie qu'actuellement les professionnelles arabes
doivent garder une maison parfaite,
s'assurer que les besoins de leurs enfants sont assouvis
et gérer leur carrière exigeante.
Pour réussir cela, j'ai découvert à mes dépends
qu'il faut appliquer les compétences professionnelles durement acquises
à votre vie personnelle.
Vous devez travailler votre vie.
Voici comment je l'applique à ma vie personnelle.
Une chose à savoir sur le Moyen-Orient :
presque chaque famille a accès à une aide ménagère abordable.
De ce fait, le défi devient de recruter efficacement.
Comme je le ferais au travail, j'ai basé la sélection
de la personne qui m'assistera auprès des enfants quand je travaille
sur une recommandation.
Cristina avait travaillé avec ma sœur pendant 4 ans
et la qualité de son travail était bien établie.
Elle est un membre intégral de notre famille,
elle est avec nous depuis qu'Alia a six mois.
Elle s'assure que tout se passe bien à la maison quand je travaille
et je m'assure de prodiguer
les conditions optimales pour elle et mes enfants,
comme je le ferais avec mon meilleur collaborateur.
Cette leçon s'applique à n'importe quelle garde d'enfants,
que ce soit une fille au pair, une garderie,
une nounou que vous partagez.
Choisissez minutieusement et responsabilisez.
En regardant mon agenda,
vous voyez que chaque jour de travail,
il y a une heure et demie, de 19h à 20h30,
bloquée et appelée « temps familial ».
C'est un moment sacré.
Je fais cela depuis qu'Alia est bébé.
Je m'assure de protéger ce moment
afin d'être à la maison et de passer du temps avec mes enfants,
qu'ils me racontent leur journée,
que je vérifie les devoirs, que je lise l'histoire du soir
et que je puisse les embrasser et les câliner.
Si je voyage, quel que soit le fuseau horaire,
j'utilise Skype pour parler à mes enfants même si je suis à des kilomètres.
Notre fils, Burhan, a 5 ans
et apprend à lire et à compter.
Voici une autre confession :
j'ai découvert que notre fille a plus de succès
que moi pour lui enseigner cela.
(Rires)
Cela était d'abord un jeu, mais Alia adore jouer à la maîtresse avec son petit frère
et j'ai découvert que ces sessions améliorent les compétences de Burhan,
augmentent le sens des responsabilités d'Alia
et renforcent les liens entre eux,
tout le monde y gagne.
Les femmes arabes prospères que je connais
ont toutes trouvé une approche unique pour travailler leur vie
tout en continuant à assumer
le gros des responsabilités dans leur maison.
Mais il ne suffit pas de survivre dans votre rôle dual
de femme qui travaille et de mère.
Il faut aussi la vivre dans le présent.
Quand je suis avec mes enfants,
je garde le travail hors de nos vies.
Au lieu de m'inquiéter du temps que je peux passer avec eux chaque jour,
je me concentre pour faire de ce temps des moments mémorables,
des moments où je vois mes enfants,
je les entends, je crée un lien avec eux.
[« Collaborez, ne rivalisez pas. »]
Les femmes arabes de ma génération n'ont pas été très visibles
dans l’œil du public depuis leur enfance.
Je crois que cela explique en partie
le faible nombre de femmes en politique dans le monde arabe.
Le bon côté de cela, cependant,
est que nous avons passé du temps
à développer officieusement une aptitude sociale
dans les cafés, les salons,
au téléphone,
une aptitude sociale très importante pour le succès :
se créer un réseau.
Je dirais que la femme arabe moyenne
a un vaste de réseau d'amis et de connaissances
dont la majorité sont des femmes.
En Occident, il semble que les femmes ambitieuses se comparent à d'autres femmes
en espérant être remarquées comme les femmes les plus prospères.
Cela entraîne un comportement compétitif
entre les femmes au travail.
Si une seule femme peut être au sommet,
il est impossible de faire de la place aux autres ou les élever.
En général, les femmes arabes
ne sont pas tombées dans ce piège psychologique.
Face à une société patriarche,
elles ont découvert qu'en s'entraidant,
tout le monde y gagnait.
Dans mon ancien travail, j'étais la femme orientale la plus gradée,
on pourrait alors penser qu'investir dans mon réseau de collègues féminines
ne m'apporterait pas grand chose
et que j'investirais mon temps
à développer mes relations avec des collègues et supérieurs masculins.
Pourtant, une de mes plus grandes percées est venu du soutien d'une autre femme.
Elle dirigeait le marketing et a suggéré
que je sois jeune dirigeante mondiale
pour le World Economic Forum.
Elle connaissait mes engagements dans les médias et mes publications
et quand on lui a demandé son avis,
elle a avancé mon nom.
C'était une jeune consultante, une amie saoudienne,
qui m'a aidée à vendre mon premier projet en Arabie Saoudite,
un marché qu'il était difficile de conquérir, en tant que femme.
Elle m'a présentée à un client
et cela a mené au premier de nombreux projets pour moi en Arabie Saoudite.
J'ai deux femmes expérimentées dans mon équipe
et je considère leur succès comme la clé de mon succès.
Les femmes avancent dans le monde,
pas assez vite, mais nous avançons.
Le monde arabe aussi fait des progrès, malgré les nombreux revers récents.
Cette année, les EAU ont nommé cinq nouvelles ministres au gouvernement,
menant le total à huit femmes ministres.
Cela représente près de 28% du gouvernement,
plus que dans beaucoup de pays développés.
C'est la photo préférée de ma fille Alia.
C'est le résultat, je n'en doute pas, d'un bon gouvernement
mais aussi de femmes arabes fortes
qui n'abandonnent pas et repoussent toujours les limites.
C'est le résultat de femmes arabes qui décident chaque jour, comme moi,
de transformer leur merde en carburant,
de travailler leur vie, de garder le travail hors de leur vie
et de collaborer, non pas de rivaliser.
En pensant au futur,
j'espère que lorsque ma fille sera sur cette scène
dans 20 ou 30 ans,
elle sera aussi fière d'être la fille de sa mère
que la fille de son père.
Pour mon fils, j'espère
que d'ici là, l'expression « fils de sa mère » ou « fils à maman »
aura pris un tout autre sens.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)